you obviously are in uh terrific
physical shape what do you do do you run
do you jazzercize do you rumble what's
happening
well i need to be motivated right now
because i play doctor on grey's anatomy
so i'm in scrubs constantly
so i need i i know i could just get i
feel like i could just get huge because
i don't have to be in like any cute
outfit necessarily so i have this new
thing that i'm doing called zombie run
what's up i don't know if anyone's heard
of this it's an app and you
run to it and you're listening to and
you have your own music so say you're
listening to like taylor swift i don't
know what you're listening to you're
running to taylor swift and
you're describing my life exactly
i thought so travel trouble trouble yeah
exactly exactly and then they'll make it
seem like zombies are chasing you at the
same time so like trouble and then
they'll be like zombies at 500 meters
and they'll be like
so it makes you run really fast it works
for me it probably sounds weird yeah
that sounds terrible
so you really believe it makes you
believe on some level that zombies are
chasing you yeah i do it at night time
so i really start to believe that
i'm being chased because it really is
like zombies two meters behind and you
start running well first of all it's
metric so i don't find that frightening
uh
i'm sorry mike what you know
camilla we're in america when someone
says someone's two meters behind me i'm
like oh that's miles away
but second of all uh so what's people
watching you jog must be you're just
running for your life screaming in the
night
yelling zombies zombies yeah actually
the other night i rounded a corner and
there was a guy with a dog and he was
bending down it was the middle of the
night and i was listening to zombie run
and i screamed in his face because he
scared me so much round in the corner i
was like oh my god yeah yeah you're a
threat to everyone around you at this
point in your life i want to mention you
were nominated to be in uh maxim's hot
100 yes yeah yeah
here's the thing i was also i was also
nominated last year this is actually a
really tragic story um my brother's this
better be tragic by the way
something tells me this isn't tragic no
anyway tell the tragic story of how you
were nominated for maxim's hot 100.
[Applause]
i am
okay so i was nominated last year and i
was told that if you're in the magazine
because i did enough to something for
the magazine that you're automatically
in the hot 100 yeah and my brothers are
extremely competitive we
they say that they're the best looking
people in the family and i was like oh
hello i'm gonna be one of the hot 100.
no big deal and i was like i'll send you
my signed maxim once i've you know oh
the minute you gloat you know you're in
trouble so what happened so i didn't
know that you that was the one year that
you had to get voted for and i had like
negative votes right
i think the only person that voted was
me for myself so you got knocked out
what place were you like the entire like
cast of twilight and the vampire diaries
like filled up the whole hundred and it
was me like 101 and my brothers were
like yes
you didn't make it so now they my
nickname is actually 101. so this year i
don't even expect to make it i'm not
even bothering two things the story is
undeniably tragic but two
i am voting for you i think you should
be in the hot one and you know what i
have a lot of pull in this town
thank you no one does this anymore
this doesn't even mean it's supposed to
be this but i do that and that's just
stupid